[MUSIC PLAYING]
JACQUELLINE FULLER: So
I am Jacquelline Fuller,
and I'm president of Google.org,
which is Google's philanthropy.
But I'm here today mostly
because I'm a friend of Justin
Dillon's.
And so I have the
honor of giving
just a brief introduction
before we bring him on
to talk to all of us.
So Justin is one of the coolest
guys I know, and he started out
as a musician.
He's an artist.
He's also a change agent
who has thought very deeply
about the issue of
slavery and trafficking
among poverty and many others.
And we actually partnered
together and really got
to know each other
when Google.org helped
with Slavery Footprint, which
was something that his team put
together to help create a
movement around modern day
slavery.
And it was just a very simple
tool that allowed consumers
around the world--
over 30 million
people, is that right?
To find out how many slaves
were involved in just
making our lifestyles happen.
What I love about
Justin is, on a topic
such as that I work with
people across the board,
from policy folks to people
who are on the ground in India
thinking about issues
like modern day slavery.
But Justin's the kind who comes
to that sort of challenging
questions and thinks, how can
we address this in the most
creative way
possible, so that we
can reach deeply into
everyone's story,
into everyone's
narrative and think
about inviting them
into a day with purpose,
a life with meaning.
And so that we're not just
talking at them about an issue,
but we're inviting them down
this path and this journey
where their life also
finds meaning while they're
helping with this issue.
And that's the topic of the book
that he has written recently.
I read it when it was in the
galley stages and I thought,
this is so incredible.
This book really,
I think, resonates
with where a lot of us are.
And, in fact, if you look
at happiness research, which
is kind of a
new-cottage industry--
it's just looking, what
does the data say about what
makes us content, what
gives us well-being
and happiness as human beings.
A lot of what we're
learning is actually
reflected in that book, and it's
about finding deeper meaning,
about finding purpose in
life through serving others,
through being part of
movements, by being part
of taking on global challenges.
So I think it's an
incredibly timely book.
I've given it as
gifts to many people,
including my daughters who
are both recently graduated
from college and really
thinking about vocation in life.
But I'm just really excited
to welcome Justin to the stage
today, on behalf of Bennett and
many other friends of Justin's
across Google.
JUSTIN DILLON: Thank you.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Thanks.
JUSTIN DILLON: Awesome.
Thank you so much.
Can you hear me OK?
I appreciate it.
One of the things that I
appreciate most about Google
is not just your
products, but the phone
calls that I get to be on,
because every one of them
is 30 minutes long.
And so I am going to give
that promise back today.
I'm going to do
everything I can to keep
all of this amazing information
I'm about to give you
within 30 minutes.
[LAUGHTER]
And we can do Q&A afterwards,
but it's really not going
to hurt my heart if we don't.
Today we're going to
talk about a few things,
but I promise you
that today we're
going to tell two stories.
We're going to talk about two
different types of poverties.
And I'm going to offer you
three takeaways for your life
that actually do
affect your life.
Because I know the
topic of purpose
seems very meta and out there.
It actually has much more
to do with how you run
your life than you might think.
I actually believe that the
most powerful force in our lives
is the lens through
which we see ourselves.
How we view our lives in
relation to how the world works
is actually nuclear.
It's very, very important
about how we look and see
how we not only
operate our lives,
but how our lives matter
to those we've never met.
So we're going to talk
a little bit about that.
But first, I want to talk about
one of my most favorite topics,
which is live music.
And I often think, you
know, if there was one show
that I could have been at,
that I was either too young
or was not living
in the right time
and place, what
would that show be?
You know, for me it
was seeing, like,
Led Zeppelin at the Forum,
or getting to see, like,
the Beatles anywhere.
Right?
Who else?
What's a show--
Daniel, I know you.
Who would you--
who didn't you get
to see that you would
have loved to have seen?
AUDIENCE: Jimi Hendrix.
JUSTIN DILLON: Yeah?
Where?
Monterey Jazz, or--
like, the guitar on fire?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Probably Monterey.
JUSTIN DILLON: OK.
Anyone else?
Is there a show
that you would have
loved to have seen that
you didn't get to see?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN DILLON: Also my favorite.
AUDIENCE: Actually, I bought
tickets for my parents,
but they didn't get
to see [INAUDIBLE]..
JUSTIN DILLON: There's a
lot of grief in the room.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
We're going to get through that.
Well, there was one
show in particular
that I wish I could have seen.
It was at a place
called Examination Hall,
which is Trinity College
in Dublin, Ireland,
specifically on
October 21, 1977.
And Trinity Hall-- excuse me.
Examination Hall
at Trinity College
isn't necessarily--
it's not the Forum.
It's not Monterey Jazz.
It's not Oakland Colosseum.
It's actually a room
where students take tests.
And it was the room of a very,
very, very important concert
that actually effected my
life and affected the lives
of many people that I know.
And when you think about a
room like this it's like,
got large cathedral halls, it's
very narrow, it's very boring.
But inside this room
on October 21 in 1977
about 1,200 Dublin
teenagers came in from--
Dublin, Ireland.
I'm sorry if I didn't tell
you it was Dublin, Ireland--
but Dublin teenagers
came in to see
what was to become the
very first punk rock
show in Ireland.
Now, these kids have given
way-- like every kid,
they're looking for
context in their lives.
They're looking for a way to
express themselves against what
was going on around them.
And frankly, they
were tired of, like,
handlebar mustaches and
disco polyester pants,
so they did something new.
And they decided
to tear those pants
and do, like,
Cleopatra-inspired mascara,
and do Anglo-European Mohawks
to be able to go to this show.
It was a big, big, big event.
And more importantly, what
was important to understand
at the time in Dublin, Ireland--
what was happening in Ireland?
It was a place that was trying
to find its national identity,
really, once again.
You know, just about 88 miles
north of the venue in Belfast
was a place of, as
many of you know,
fantastic sectarian violence.
There was terrorist attacks,
like, Molotov cocktails,
gunshots.
That was an average Tuesday
for people in the north.
So really Ireland,
at this point,
was a place of trying to
find itself through violence,
through nationalism.
I don't know of any that
sounds familiar to you at all.
But inside this
room these students
were trying to figure
out who they were.
And the band that was
coming on stage in 1977
was a new punk band
called The Clash.
Now, if you're under
40 you probably
don't know who
they are, but this
was a band that had
only been around
at this point for
just, like, one year.
And the lead singer--
I'm not sure if-- oh.
He's the guy in the middle.
His name is Joe Strummer--
had actually been born
a child of privilege.
You know, Joe Strummer was a
diplomat's son whose parents
dropped him off at a--
basically to be raised
by another school.
And he realized that
privilege wasn't the way
that he wanted to live.
So when he got
out of high school
he started living in the
south side of London.
He lived with the
disenfranchised
and the minorities, and
actually became an advocate
in his own way.
And his advocacy was to
find a way to play music.
And that's how The
Clash got started.
And so when Joe got
started, really it
was a way of being able to
express what was inside of him
and bring it to others.
And punk rock really became
the recipe and The Clash
were just the chefs.
Now, it's important
to note that what
was happening behind the band.
And this is obviously
Belfast in 1977.
But this is a
picture of the tour
in which they were playing at
this time on October 21, 1977.
And what was behind
the band is a backdrop
of a picture of a
race riot in London.
And this is where
black communities
were coming together to be able
to stand up for their rights.
And these disenfranchised
minorities
were really a big part of
who Joe was standing up for
and The Clash were
standing up for.
In fact, really what's
interesting about the clash
is that they were a white band
playing to white audiences
about black music.
And when Joe stepped up to
the mic for the first time,
the crowd went wild because
he yelled out "white riot."
I'm going to-- I'm
not going to sing.
Don't worry.
Because you don't want that.
But I'm going to
read them to you.
"White riot.
I want a riot.
White riot, a riot of my own.
Black people got
a lot of problems,
but they don't mind
throwing a brick.
White people go to school,
where they teach you
how to be thick."
You see, what Joe is saying
to this mainly white audience
was that black
people have to riot.
They have to riot to survive,
but white people don't.
And as a person who has grown--
he had grown up with privilege.
His message was, if you can't
find your own riot, if you
can't stand up for
something, you're
going to live a half life.
You're just going to be
another, in his words,
another "thick" bloke.
His message to everyone,
and our message today,
is to find your riot.
Find something to stand up for.
Find something
bigger than yourself.
Now, back in the back
of Examination Hall
were four teenagers
who were taking this
all in as if it
was, like, you know,
a messianic prophetic preacher
at a tent evangelist show.
They were just looking
at this as just
being blown away at everything
that they were seeing.
And they realized inside
of them that this--
this was it.
This was their message.
They were going to
find their riot.
And again, you know,
anyone under 40 years old
probably won't
know who they are,
but they were just
here a few months ago.
They went on to become U2.
This band found
their riot, and they
realized that it wasn't
just about what you do
and how you live
and what you get,
but it's about how you leverage
who you are and what you are
and what you're good at for
the problems of other people
who can never repay you.
Purpose isn't
happiness, and we're
going to talk a little bit
further about that today.
But these lads were
able to find it,
were able to find their riot.
"Purpose" is a big
word, and it's one
that I think we don't
pay enough attention to.
I actually believe that we're
living in a global purpose
crisis.
Only today we have infinite
suitors coming at us
at all times of the
day promising purpose,
but in reality we're just
being offered amusement.
You see, many of us have
reached the very top
of Maslow's hierarchy of needs
and we're no longer foraging
for food and for shelter.
We're forging for something
that matters in our lives.
I think this guy said it best.
"He who has a why
can endure any how."
And I actually believe that
standing up for something
that you want
changed in the world
is actually not noble
or selfless or otherly
or something to be respected.
It's actually selfish, and
it's actually survival.
Because the only way that
you're going to be able to find
true purpose is to take
on the problems of others.
You see, in this equation
purpose is our why to live,
not just our how.
We're handling
everythings every day.
The promise is how to be helpy--
the promises how to be happy--
and helpy-- and these are
our how, but they're not--
they're not our why.
And the pursuit of happiness
is pretty straightforward.
It's found through
acquiring and achieving.
But how do we find our why?
How do we find our purpose?
I've had a book out
for a few months
and, you know, you don't
really pay attention
to the people who you
don't know that read it.
You pay attention to the people
who you do know who read it.
And specifically you
really pay attention
to the people who you do
know who haven't read it,
because that's where
it gets personal.
[CHUCKLES]
And one person in particular--
and I actually have to say,
this friend of mine is someone--
I won't say who he is--
he's actually someone I
kind of wrote the book for.
Like, the archetype,
the type of person.
And he told me-- he's like, you
know, this is great and all,
but I've got,
like, bills to pay,
and I've got kids to
get through school,
and I've got all the rest of it.
And purpose and
meaning, frankly--
they sound otherly.
They sound meta.
I hear people tell
me this all the time.
It's like, yeah, I'll--
eventually I'll buy a Tesla,
but it's not for right now.
That's what purpose is.
It's a Tesla in
most people's lives.
[CHUCKLES]
This is because we think
of an understanding
that the why of our life,
the pursuit of meaning,
is somehow extra, something
that we can figure out
once we have our how,
once we have everything
that we feel like we need.
There's lots of
definitions for purpose,
but this is the one that
I find the most helpful.
Purpose isn't how much you can
give or what you can donate
or what cause you're
associated with.
Listen to this.
It's finding what the world
needs from you, finding out
what the world needs from you.
Here's the thing.
Charity is going to tell you--
and I've run one for 10 years--
will tell you that
the world needs
you to give to support that.
I actually don't believe that.
They need you to give, and
it is extremely important
that we all support charities.
But that's not purpose.
You were designed to fix
problems in the world.
If you aren't fixing your own
needs of just having to put
a roof over your head
and food on the plate,
you're actually designed--
and your purpose--
is to fix the needs and
fix the problems of others.
It's not ancillary.
It's actually a big,
big part of your why.
So the point of my book
and the point of my talk
is to try to solve a
lot of problems at once.
What if we could change the
world and improve our lives?
You see, my friend who
doesn't have time for this,
he just needs to make them--
he's got problems in his life.
Those are more important.
And frankly, I don't
argue with him.
But he's missing out,
because he doesn't know
what the world needs from him.
What if we could solve
our "how to live" problems
while also solving our
"why am I here" problems,
while also solving
the problems of others
who can never pay us back?
In my book I propose
a model to be
able to help us understand this.
And I've actually
arranged all of humanity
into two different groups, two
different types of poverties.
The first poverty is
a poverty of means.
This is the poverty that
most of us are familiar with.
This is the poverty
that we see on our feeds
and we see in the news.
We know what this
poverty looks like.
But I've put a word next to it
that I think is helpful for us
to understand.
And Jacquelline was
talking earlier about,
in some ways, how
I see the world.
The word "means" is very,
very important here.
"Means" actually means
an action or a system
by which a result
is brought about.
OK.
So to bring that down,
a "poverty of means"
simply means that there's
an action or a system that's
missing.
Poverty is no longer
just about a condition.
Right?
It's that something's missing.
So when we say that there's
844 million people who
don't have access to clean
water, what we're saying
is there's a poverty of means
to wells to offer clean water.
When we say there's 400 million
people that are suffering just
for basic health, we're
saying that there's
a poverty of means to medicine
and care to that health.
When we say that there's 40
million people plus living
in slavery today, it's a
poverty of means of justice.
Now, this is the
poverty of means
that I wrestle with every
day, the poverty of justice.
We're missing an
action or a system
where there should be one.
My day job is to build a
means and to fix a system that
allows children to be
exploited every day in order
to support our lifestyles.
Slavery is reprehensible.
And it actually needs
more than our attention
and our care and our reposts.
It's a thriving business
and it's a moral outrage,
because it's a
system that works.
So it needs an action or a
system to make it stop working.
This is extremely evident
when I visit places
like Ghana out on Lake
Volta and I meet little boys
like this, Ebenezer, who
works on a boat every day
for 17 hours a
day to catch fish.
He's controlled by a.
Master Ebenezer is suffering
a poverty of means.
And so is his little
brother, who's
asleep at the top of the boat.
And when I talked
to his master--
who is in the red
shirt-- and I ask him
why is this little
boy working and not
in school, his answer to
me is, if he doesn't work,
I don't eat.
I'm sorry, but that's
also a poverty of means.
So you can get how slavery
is a hot mess on this planet,
and it needs more
than just donations.
It needs a system, and it
needs an action to break it.
And it's heartbreaking.
But our breaking
hearts aren't enough.
It actually needs us to step in.
The other poverty that
I want to talk about
is also fantastically-insidious.
It's a poverty of meaning.
This is a poverty
that many of us--
some of us, and certainly
people we know--
are living beneath
its poverty line.
It's not one that people
talk about very often,
but it still claims lives.
I'm going to say that again.
It claims the lives of
thousands of people every year.
It causes disease,
uproots communities,
and has even played a role in
creating a few wars or two.
While it doesn't rob us of
food or water or medicine
or justice, it steals something
that's very valuable to us all.
We already saw it.
It steals our why.
It takes away our why to live.
And as we learned earlier,
it's difficult to know
how to live if we don't
have a why, if we don't know
what the world needs from us.
What's scary is that many of us
are scraping by in our lives,
unaware that this poverty
is eating at our heels.
While it doesn't take
nearly the amount of lives
a year that the poverty of
means takes, it's still lethal.
And we can see it.
Maybe not directly, but
indirectly in the data,
where 50% of people on social
media between 18 and 34
feel ugly and
worthless and otherly.
And 30% of those people feel
extreme amounts of loneliness.
In fact, one in five
people in America
feel extremely and
debilitatingly lonely.
And all the data that's
coming out on loneliness
is directing-- is saying
to us, that it's actually
creating health problems,
heart disease, diabetes.
These things are connected.
Meaning and health and
wealth and how we live
are all connected.
If we don't know
our why and we don't
know what the world wants from
us, in some ways we perish.
Not just existentially,
literally perish.
If anyone understands this
existential and physical
perishing best it's Dr. Frankl.
Dr. Frankl understood this
need better than anyone,
because he wrote in
his popular book,
"Man's Search for Meaning."
If you read it you'll learn
that he was a psychiatrist.
It's a very popular book.
You might have already
actually read it.
He was a psychiatrist around
World War II that ended up
in a concentration camp.
And he tasked himself
to save the people who
were killing themselves.
And he knew he could
tell when someone
was going to kill themselves
because they started
smoking their cigarettes.
You see, cigarettes
in concentration camps
were currency.
You didn't smoke them.
You traded them for things
you needed like food or a day
off from work.
But when you started smoking
the only thing of value
you have in your
life, Dr. Frankl
knew that they were close
to committing suicide.
And his primary argument
with every one of them
was that the world needed
something for them.
There was still something that
the world needed from them.
It was his main argument
inside of a concentration camp
to help people understand
not just a poverty of means,
but their own
poverty of meaning.
His message, like
Joe's, is the same.
The world wants
something from you.
The world wants your riot.
It wants you to know.
It wants to know what you
care about, and actually
wants you to act on it.
If we don't find our riot, we
suffer and the world around us
misses a chance to improve.
Your riot is the voice
inside of you that says,
I wish something was
different in the world.
Now, I found my
riot later in life.
I came upon the issue
of human trafficking
and it hijacked my heart.
And I had every opportunity to
keep moving with what was then
a music career.
But I said, you know, I just--
I'm going to give this
thing that's inside of me
a little bit of gas.
Not a lot.
I don't want to change my life.
I don't to do this
for 10 years--
even though I have.
I don't want to do that.
I'm just going to--
I'm just going to lob
one over the fence.
I want to try something.
Because what I saw working
around this issue 10 years ago,
what I saw people doing,
frankly didn't seem like enough.
And at the time I was a
part of the music community.
I'm like, well, can't have
a movement without music.
Let's get it on.
And so I pulled a bunch of
musicians together during
Grammys week in 2007
and I said, let's--
here was my business plan.
Let's make some-- let's
film some performances
and then let's give them away,
and we'll talk about slavery
on top of it.
That was my business plan.
And actually people agreed.
And so people came to a
studio in Santa Monica
and filmed these beautiful
performances for me
that I had no idea
what to do with.
And after two days of
filming I'm like, wow,
that went really good.
Like, people really
love doing this.
Guess what?
People actually love doing what
they're good at to help others.
I think we're on to something.
And so I decided to do it again.
I did it in New York, and
then in Austin, in London.
And all these musicians
started coming together.
And then I thought, well, we
should get some smart people
to talk about it.
So let's call up Nick
Kristof and Dr. Cornel West
and Madeline Albright.
And I quickly learned how,
you know, films like Borat
get made because no one checks.
They let you in to
interview people.
It's amazing.
They check now.
But no one checked
back then, and I
was able to interview
these very important people
and learn something
and allow them
to contribute their voices.
We made a movie, and the
movie went through theaters.
Now I'm two years in.
My music career is way
behind me at this point.
And then we make some websites,
like Slavery Footprint.
And then we make
some documentaries,
and on and on it goes.
And people continue
to get involved.
And then we made
something really exciting,
Enterprise Software.
(WHISPERING) Oh my gosh.
Enterprise software that
helps businesses identify
forced labor in
their supply chains.
In 10 years.
Folks, I used to count to
four and rhyme for a living.
That was music.
When you reach out and you
take a step towards your riot,
you have no idea what
you're capable of.
You have no idea how
powerful your how
operates in this world.
That is how you find
purpose, by taking
on the problems of others who
can not ever possibly pay you
back.
I want to talk about
how to find your riot.
You know, we hear
this all the time.
It's like, that's great,
find your purpose,
all the rest of it.
Not very many
people give us a way
in which we can take
a step towards that.
And I want to introduce you
to someone who, to me, just
lives finding a riot
better than anyone else.
It's probably someone
you've never heard of.
Her name is Alice
Harris, and she grew up
in the late 19th century.
And her dream-- her dream was
to be a missionary to Africa.
She met a man,
John, and they got
sent to what was then the free
state of Congo, which happened
to be a territory in Africa
that was not yet colonized,
one of the largest territories
in Africa around 1900.
And there they did their
missionary work, very noble
work.
Actually, it was a
part of a larger system
because at the time
there was a lot of work
to be able to help
educate and bring science
to the region, which actually
turned out to be a ploy.
But they were doing their bit.
They were doing what
they were good at,
and they were doing their
life the way they saw fit.
And one day when John
was away on business,
her husband was
away on business--
they had no children.
When John was away on business
one of the local tribes-people
came to her door and said,
I really want to see you.
I want to see you, specifically.
His name was Nasala.
And Nasala came up and said,
I have something to show you.
And she came and he set it out
and he brought this plantain
leaf, and he set it
out onto her veranda.
He's like, I need you
to see what's happening.
And so she walked
up and it's really--
let me go back here.
As she came upon the
open plantain leaf
that Nasala brought she realized
that it was the severed hand
and foot of his daughter.
I'm going to stop there and
tell you why that happened.
See, over in Belgium
there was this mad King
called King Leopold II.
And he was very jealous of all
the other leaders in Europe
because everyone else got to
colonize Africa and he didn't.
And actually, colonization
at this point in history--
people were starting
to look down on it.
Slavery is kind of illegal-ish.
And so he had to figure out a
way to get his own land grab.
So he created a
company, basically
an institute, that was able
to go in and quote unquote,
"bring science and education"
to this entire region.
But what it really
was was a ploy
to be able to start pulling
out the natural resources that
were in the Congo.
And he named it the Free State
of Congo, believe it or not.
And what he did was he set up a
police force called the "Force
Publique" who would
go out and take land
from local tribes-people
and then force
them to work the land.
And, in fact, what
they were really
finding was-- one of the
hottest commodities that
was coming out of Congo
at this time was rubber.
And rubber was in big
demand because bike tires
and automobiles were just
really getting started.
And basically what
Leopold was doing
was creating this illicit
business in slavery
and just making a fortune.
But he was a total cheapskate.
Total cheapskate.
He wanted an accounting
of every single bullet
that his force used.
So he required them--
because he was
afraid that they were
going to go out and use bullets
to go hunt game for themselves
and whatnot.
So what he required-- if
you're going to shoot a bullet,
I need to see a hand
or a foot to prove
that you killed someone.
And the Force Publique
got kind of smart about it
and so they figured, well, let's
just get ahead of the game.
Let's go hack off hands
and feet and get ahead.
That way our accounting
system will work
when we come back at the end.
And that's how you
get Nasala's story.
So here Alice is looking at
what's happening on her door,
on that veranda, on those
steps, in that moment
she found her riot.
She found her purpose.
And here's the takeaway.
This is what she did.
She walked back inside, she
grabbed the coolest thing
she had, which was a Kodak
brownie camera, which
was the coolest piece of tech
you could have at the time,
and it was affordable,
that she took that picture.
I'll show you again.
And she didn't stop there.
She went on taking
more and more pictures.
And she started documenting
the atrocities that
were happening all over Congo.
No one else was doing
this at the time.
And she realized that something
inside of her was happening.
Guess what she didn't do?
She didn't ask
anyone's permission.
Don't you think
you'd want permission
to go try to take down
a European leader?
That sounds like
something you would
want to call in a professional
for, or get something
a little bit bigger than a
demure missionary from England.
But she kept going.
And then she realized, in
order to get the word out--
because Leopold was fighting her
left and right in the papers,
keeping her pictures
from getting out--
so she said forget it.
I'm going to go
on a magic lantern
tour-- which is essentially the
1900s version of PowerPoint.
And she took her pictures
all around America, all
around England,
and started getting
the attention of Mark
Twain and the president
and the Queen of England with
a very short amount of time.
His entire reign was
shut down, and he
was no longer able to
exploit the people of Congo.
This one woman found her
riot, and took a step,
and was able to change an entire
system, a poverty of means,
purely because she was
able to do something
without permission.
So the takeaway that
I give you today
is that, when you
look for your riot--
my right is obviously
human trafficking.
Our riots don't need to
be in a faraway place.
Your riot-- the thing
that could bug you
is the fact that not enough
kids in your neighborhood
have parents helping
them with their homework
because they all work and have
two jobs and they're too busy.
That's a riot.
It doesn't have to be
something this big.
And if it's a thing
that bothers you,
if it's a thing inside
of you that says,
I wish the world was this
way, I want to challenge you.
You might be the one to fix it.
She could have left Nasala
on the porch and said,
I'm so sorry.
I'll go write a letter.
I'll do what I can.
Instead, she grabbed
what she already had,
the talent and the skills
and the possessions
that she already had, and
started working on it.
Anyone-- anyone in here
can find their riot
and act on it as long as they
don't ask permission and just
choose to use what
you already have.
When Dr. King gave his
message at Oberlin College
he spoke to this
need for meaning.
He called it an inescapable
network of mutuality.
And he said that, I am not who
I am supposed to be until you
are who you're supposed to be.
And you're not who
you're supposed
to be until the
person next to you
is who they're supposed to be.
And in a global village
like we live in today,
that axiom is true
on a global scale.
We actually find ourselves
when we give ourselves
away to people's problems
who can never pay us back.
That is your path
to purpose, and that
is how you find your riot.
And I want to thank you all
for letting me have this time
to be able to do this.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you.
So, Ben is the one
that set this up.
Thank you so much.
Your love.
This is somebody
who found his riot,
and is a living
example of someone who
makes a difference
every day, and I
want to thank you for that.
You know, shake it off.
You're just doing--
AUDIENCE: Any questions
for the author here?
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming
and for the very inspiring
talk.
I wanted to get your
perspective on kind
of finding the right riot and
kind of the anaylsis paralysis
of waiting for the right
one, or just doing something.
And it comes from
the perspective of,
one's life gives you
a lot of training.
Sometimes it takes long to
find something that says, hey,
this is really using the
most leverage that I got.
So I struggle a lot-- and
probably others-- like,
sometimes I feel like I'm
waiting for that bigger thing.
And the motivation for
that is, like, maybe it
is wasted that I just
help in some capacity that
didn't use all their
unique skills and stuff
that life has given me.
So I just wanted to
get your thoughts
on how do you feel one can
maybe go through that process
where ultimately you end up
using all of what you've got.
And how do you get there?
Like, do you start very
small and then grow to it?
Or do you--
I don't know.
I keep on thinking of, quote
unquote, your "strategy"
and your large-scale,
high-impact
so on-- and so forth.
So I was just curious how--
Or, if you think, hey,
maybe you shouldn't
use all of your skill.
It's OK just to underutilize
maybe what life has given you,
and it's also OK.
So--
JUSTIN DILLON: Yeah.
Those are great questions.
I actually believe that
change happens at small scale.
Part of the thing about writing
a book and putting movies out--
it just-- it makes it
seem really glamorous.
And I'm fortunate to have my
favorite person in the world,
my wife, here today.
And she can attest to you
that there is just, like,
very little glamor in
trying to change the world.
It is a million small steps in
trying to make a difference.
And also doing things that
you are interested in, but
aren't necessarily good at.
I mean, does Google still have
that thing where you-- like,
what, 20% or 30% of time to
work on things that-- really?
Do you use it?
[LAUGHTER]
Because, you know,
some great things
have come out of that model.
And I would argue that there's
some very, very talented folks
here.
And if you've got that
level and that wide
of a berth of the
opportunity to try things,
I think you can create
some wonderful things here
with this network.
But again-- and I know it's
weird to say this to Google,
but I really do think
you have to think small.
You know?
Like, people come to me all the
time, like, let's do a concert,
or let's create an
app that ends slavery.
It's like, you know, let's
just get a few companies
to look at their supply chain.
Wow, that's boring.
My goodness is it so impactful.
We're not, like, playing with
thousands of dollars now.
We're playing with billions.
You know?
But it's not-- it's
not as sexy as, like--
so I think that we really
do need to scale back
our ambitions around what
something looks like and put
more of our ambition
on, like, what's
something that can
just help out a little?
You know, helping out a
kid with their homework
seems like a little,
but it's a lot.
It's fantastic.
So I think we have
to kind of divorce
ourselves from the idea that
all change is glamorous.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was just wondering how
you measure your impact?
Is it, like, in a
financial system
as we are currently used to?
You know, like, by quarter by
quarter, this kind of stuff?
Or do you base as well
with public policies,
implementations, for example?
With sustainable development
goals for the UN--
I used to work for the UN and
then I moved to go Google.
I did some partnerships
back in Brazil
with indigenous communities.
But then I see our public
policies going backwards.
You know?
Like, I see the indigenous
rights in Brazil, for example,
you know, being disrespected.
So I'm glad to hear from
you as well about that.
JUSTIN DILLON: Yeah.
I think change is juggling
chainsaws and walking.
That's what it looks like.
Because one chain
saw is public policy,
one chain saw is
the marketplace,
one chain saw is the
economy of attention.
It's very expensive to get into.
It isn't just one thing.
And over the last
10 years we've seen
enormous growth, an enormous
difference made around slavery.
But I can't tell you
how many rooms I've
been in-- important
rooms, like, you know,
rooms you've heard
of where people
slam their hand on the table and
say, you're not doing enough,
and then they go back to
their pulpit or they go back
to their desk and go
back on with their job.
Because people expect, when
something's really bad,
like slavery, that it should
just be fixed very easily.
It's entrenched in
everything we do.
And so it requires some move--
a little bit of
movement on policy.
Some movement in
the marketplace.
Some movement around consumers,
I mean, in the work that we do.
And I would assume it's
the same everywhere else.
For us we had to, like, roll
it all back as a company.
We had to roll it all back
to, like, what does change
look like for us?
Oh.
Guess what?
It's really boring.
It actually means
how many companies
are looking at how
many of their suppliers
and measuring where slavery
might be in that supply chain?
And it turns out
that, as we started
moving towards that as a
company and trying to figure out
how to measure that-- because
you can't fix a problem
you can't measure.
And to my knowledge there has
been no census on slaves since,
like, maybe 150 years ago.
So how do you
measure a problem--
how do you fix a problem
you can't measure?
So we're measuring
it for companies
and actually giving them a way
to be able to step forward.
[SNAPS] Now the lights went on.
Now we can actually
look at how we
can fix a problem that's
been with us for a long time
and probably will continue.
So it does take a
bit of iteration,
but I think
sometimes people just
go hard on public policy
being-- oh, if we can just get
a law passed, that'll be it.
And it's just-- that's
just one chainsaw.
My opinion.
Did all of those, like,
weird metaphors help at all?
Because I have a--
I don't get the sense they did.
We can sidebar.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
the supply chain for companies.
Where is your company
going and where do you
need the help in
your company itself?
JUSTIN DILLON: We just
need as many companies
using our software as possible.
We're the only
software out there
that can measure slavery
beyond the first-tier supplier.
And actually most
people will say, oh,
we're talking to all of
our first-tier suppliers.
There's 10,000 or 20,000.
They're all good.
It's usually not where
the problems are.
We actually need
to be able to use
optics, the optics
we provide, to be
able to push beyond tier-one
and understand where
the problems are, and get those
relationships between buyer
and seller to kind of push
further and change behavior
in the supply chain.
And we're seeing it happen
at a very large scale.
But it is going to take the
coalition of the willing,
so to speak, in the marketplace
to all work together.
And in a competitive marketplace
where one company doesn't
want to share all their secrets,
this isn't something you want--
I'd like for people to be
competitive on slavery.
But competitive on
knowing where it is
and ending it-- that's the best
way to be competitive on this.
Yeah.
Thank you everyone for coming.
Thanks everyone
who are watching.
If you want to get the book--
there's some books in the back.
There's books online.
"A Selfish Plan to
Change the World."
Thanks, man.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Justin.
JUSTIN DILLON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]